if you go back into the four
congresswomen the things they've said
about our country are terrible what
they've said about Israel are just
terrible I don't know I can't say for
sure but certainly a lot of people say
they hate our country and I think it's a
disgrace what they've said I think you
can't talk that way about the United
States and I think frankly to say that
about Israel you know we just gave the
embassy in Jerusalem making Jerusalem
the capital of Israel I just gave Golan
Heights recognized Golan Heights for
Israel I've done all of this for Israel
and then you have these people I think
that Omar I find it hard to believe but
I hear Omar today put in or yesterday
put in a sanctions bill against Israel
and other things beyond sanctions so
when I hear that you just can't talk
about our country that way and when
people are angry at them I fully
understand it
I don't know if it's good or bad
politically I don't care but when people
are speaking so badly when they call our
country garbage think of that that's
worse than the plural well they call our
country garbage I don't care about
politics I don't care if it's good or
bad about politics many people say it's
good I don't know if it's good or bad I
can tell you this you can't talk that
way about our country not when I'm the
president so I think they've said
horrible things they're anti-semitic and
you look at the kind of statements they
made about Israel it's a disgrace to say
what they want about our country that's
what the Constitution guarantees do you
see not agreeing with you as the same
thing as hating the country yeah they
have First Amendment rights but that
doesn't mean I'm happy about them saying
and when they say bad things about us we
can certainly feel and again we have
First Amendment rights also we can
certainly feel what and say what we want